le pays des kangourous suffoque dans la
chaleur aidant la fumée cette image de
sydney est suffisamment parlante
seul le haut des gratte ciels émergent
du brouillard toxiques l'état d'urgence
vient d'être déclarée pour une semaine
entière dans l'état des nouvelles galles
du sud
les pompiers de cette région la plus
peuplée d'australie ne vois pas comment
venir à bout des incendies qui font rage
depuis plusieurs semaines les piscines
deviennent des alliés précieux pour
freiner la progression des flammes
une torture qui n'en finit pas pour
l'instant six victimes et des maisons
détruites par dizaines mais l'inquiétude
des autorités sanitaires
c'est surtout la qualité de l'air il y
aura des conséquences à long terme pour
ceux qui s'exposent à la pollution dit
cet expert
et si le premier ministre fédéral
australien refusent de faire le lien
avec le réchauffement de la planète
décisif ce ministre provincial de
l'environnement est formel l'intensité
des feux de broussailles et de la vague
de chaleur porte la marque des
changements climatiques
nouveau record ce 19 décembre il a fait
en moyenne 41,9 degrés dans toute
l'australie ici mathieu prost
radio-canada à montréal où il fait juste
soixante degrés de moins